come on did you really think they were
finished bub so on the show I try and
avoid talking about rumors stuff that's
uncomfirmed I try and confine most of my
videos to stuff that has actually been
confirmed by whoever's making it or at
least is being reported by a pretty
reliable news source so normally
something goes like oh we're talking
about maybe doing this I wouldn't talk
about but in this case it I've got
thoughts that I do want to get out there
so and that is that James Mangold
director of Logan and the Wolverine has
said that he is currently having
conversations about what a spin-off or
sequel to Logan's starring the character
of Laura aka x-23 might look like now we
don't have a lot of details from him
about what they're talking about but we
do now know that conversations are are
happening my initial thought on that I
am on board with that I think she was a
fantastic character the actress whose
name I I'm drawing a blank on I'll put
it right down here but she was really
really good in that role she had great
energy she had a great dynamic with
every character that she interacted with
she sold the action scenes really well
she could be intense you did a good job
expressing the weight of what her
character had been through and yet there
was still there was there was that real
spark of life and soul in her that you
made you want to see her succeed so I
think a spin-off movie starring her a
centered around her that yes
I'm absolutely on board with that
however after thinking about it for a
few minutes I I did start to occur to me
like ooh there might be a problem here
and not like an automatic problem but
reasons that I'm that sort of don't dial
back my enthusiasm but make me cautious
which is that as much as I would love to
see an X 23 movie it would also be
effectively a Logan sequel and Logan
does not need a sequel and I don't just
mean that in terms of like a spoilers
eyes at the end of it and you know he
can't come back and be and more I mean
that in the terms of what they should
not they absolutely should not do is be
trying to recapture what Logan was and
that's you often what you do with
sequels because Logan the more you think
about it is a kind of a fluke
it's a weird movie it is a hard are
depressing deliberately unsatisfying
excellently made film and again hard are
starring a actor and a character that
has been in a pg-13 franchise for almost
twenty years that's nuts
and the fact that a it happened to be it
worked as well as it did that that is
not the kind of success that you are
going to be able to repeat because it
was under really specific circumstances
so the worst thing that could happen is
they try and recapture that feel and
ways that they could do that would be
like if they try and make the character
of Laura more like Logan obviously they
can't like age her up or into that
except well I mean I suppose they're you
get an older actress but that would be
really dumb I don't think they would
even consider that but I mean like put
her in a similar mentality as a
character to how Logan was in that film
I in terms of like being you know done
with it and grizzled and beaten down
they could push her in that direction
and I think that would be a massive
massive mistake on so many levels
because like I said trying to recapture
what Logan was that's how you end up
just spinning your wheels whereas I
think there was a ton of potential in
this character for her to actually move
forward and do something new in this
world and we and her as a character she
was a deliberate contrast Logan she had
a great sense of life about her Logan as
a character did not that was a big part
of their dynamic so and also if she ends
up like him in terms of how beaten down
he was
then what was his sacrifice for at the
end of his movie if she's just gonna end
up like that
so by honoring the original they need to
they need to basically have her be I
don't want to go so far as to say a
beacon of hope but to be an active force
you know for the things she believes in
in a way that Logan really wasn't in
that film so something something this is
something I'd like to see anyway but I
would take this as a signifier that they
are not gonna do what I'm afraid they're
gonna do and that would be I want her in
the costume the x-23 costume couple
reasons first I just think it would look
cool but secondly it would show me that
they're not trying to make her be Logan
because you're putting on that costume
which is a costume
yeah it's obviously based off the
original Wolverine costume and it's one
we've never seen in a movie at all it
got teased in a deleted scene on the
Wolverine he's never worn it so it would
be taking the character it would be
taking her as a character in a different
direction but also giving her a frankly
slightly more comic book ish more heroic
feel and I think that's the right way to
go with the character and I think it's
an easily justified movies walk because
I'm sure there's some people going what
is that how grounded Logan was you've
got to put her in that costume yes I'm
gonna put her in that costume because
think about it she was reading these
comic books they get established in the
movie Logan so there are comic books
about the exploits of the x-men and they
are comic books up they're not accurate
but they were what became her vision and
those of other young news like her of
what the x-men were the reality of it is
almost irrelevant because this is the
myth and the legend of it and Wolverine
in that comic had the costume so in
terms of both trying to honor the
sacrifice that she made for her
also be the better version than the
reality ever was Shay could totally buy
and would encourage that she would make
and wear that costume and again it would
be such an indication that they're not
gonna try and just do the depressing
lightning in a bottle that was the first
Logan again that they are gonna move
things forward and again you don't have
to like make the world like suddenly you
know bright and cheery and and you know
MCU spider-man homecoming looking kind
of thing no just do that with her keep
the world the same sort of dirty used up
slightly barren kind of western desert
town feel that it had and Logan but you
can still move the characters forward
and not have them wallow in pain the way
that Logan did and none of these things
that I'm saying are criticisms of Logan
as a film it absolutely worked in that
film but it's not gonna work if they do
it again and I think it's basically a
matter of whether or not Fox gets out of
James Mangold's way now James Mangold is
not a perfect filmmaker I'm not like oh
he can't possibly mess this up but the
things that I'm afraid of are the sorts
of things that the corporate mentality
does because at the studio level at the
executive level they look at a success
and go oh that's what worked repeat as
many of those elements as we possibly
can and hopefully it'll work again
that's studio executive mentality and
that is what will kill an X 23 movie if
it in fact ever gets made so as long as
they leave him alone and let him make
his own movie and potentially make his
own mistakes as I said the man's human
he's not a perfect filmmaker but I think
we're gonna be in much better hands if
they just back off from this and let him
do whatever he's gonna do and as I said
I hope what he's gonna do would involve
the costume so those are my thoughts on
X 23 reasons to be excited but also
something to watch out for which is
often what I do it it can it can be hard
for me to be totally positive because
there's what there's a part of my brain
I can't stop from going okay yeah that's
good no but here's the ways it could go
wrong it's a thing that happens I'm
sorry in any case what are your thoughts
on the possibility of an ex 23
movie whatever they are good bad excited
nervous drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it don't
forget to like subscribe check me out on
Twitter at Council of geeks give a
listen to the council of geese podcast
available on iTunes and stitcher I am
also one half of the punch like a girl
podcast that can be found on the fire
and water podcast network fire and water
podcast.com and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]